I despise cronyism and corruption and I
recently learned that the FBI has a new
headquarters in the works they've got a
1.7 billion dollar contract that's up
for grabs to build their new building in
the Washington DC area and it turns out
that one of the three finalists that's
being considered for that contract is a
company that just so happens to own
buildings with both the Trump
Organization and Jared Kushner's family
a 21 billion-dollar real estate
investment firm called vornado Realty
trust Vornado owns buildings with Trump
in New York and San Francisco as well as
the flagship skyscraper for Kushner
companies in New York City which happens
to be 666 Fifth Avenue a little ominous
anyway that building has had conflict of
interest scandals in the past related to
investors and the Chinese government but
this here is a clear and obvious
conflict of interest especially since as
you probably remember Donald Trump never
divested from his company when he became
president Virginia congressman Gerald
Connelly who represents a part of
Virginia where the new FBI building
might be built told Vornado dropped the
bid he said to the Associated Press
quote that shifts the ethical burden to
his business partners were in a position
where once again he shrugged off his
responsibilities and slat is it France
cloud or [ __ ] left cloud it off fluffed
it off someone else I've never known how
to pronounce that word anyway vornado
has refused to comment on the situation
the Trump Organization and Jared
Kushner's company have refused to
comment on the situation the White House
sent in a statement quote Jared takes
the ethics rules very seriously hard to
even read it with a straight face and
would never compromise himself or the
administration hard to hard to get
through that one well now I'm reassured
so we have no real answers from anyone
involved and maybe you're saying all
right we'll listen vornado isn't owned
by anyone in the White House and there
isn't necessarily a conflict here
vornado CEO Stephen Roth also happens to
be very close to
Donald Trump and is one of Donald
Trump's advisors about infrastructure
should an infrastructure advisor to the
federal government be profiting from the
building of a federal government
physical infrastructure Roth is also a
consultant for the White House Office of
American innovation a new office created
by the way by Donald Trump and run
coincidentally by Jared Kushner Stephen
schooner who's a professor of government
procurement law at George Washington
University said this is very suspect he
wrote in an email quote this would
absolutely pose an apparent and
potentially an actual conflict of
interest I cannot imagine any modern era
precedent for the president and his
advisor and son-in-law not recognizing
that this is a problem and shutting this
down before it gets any worse there are
endless conflicts of interest this is
another version of Dick Cheney's
Halliburton all over again this is a
level of cronyism reminiscent of Russia
don't worry though Russia is also
interested in building the new FBI
headquarters would be super secure don't
worry about it I'm kidding about that I
want to make sure people realize that's
just a joke I mean is it possible that
Donald Trump being this big business
magnate having all of these real estate
places all across the world that he's
just tied to so many people that you
can't really avoid conflicts of interest
you could make that argument that is the
one argument you could make but still to
maintain the lack of an appearance of
impropriety Vornado should just say
we're not going to bid on this because
we are connected there are companies
that could do the job that are not
connected to Donald Trump and this gets
me into the next thing I want to briefly
address